Hello.
I'm Roman Nurik from the
Android Developer Relations
team at Google.
In today's DevByte, we're
going to take a look
at the new immersive mode
feature in Android 4.4 KitKat.
This feature lets your
apps go truly full screen.
Let's take a look.
So before we talk
about immersive mode,
let's recap all of the
different full screen
APIs there were available in
previous versions of Android.
Now, there are two sets
of APIs for full screen.
The first is a set of
window manager flags,
such as flag
fullscreen, you can set
or unset to show or
hide the status bar.
Now, these work on any
version of Android,
and remain active even if you
navigate away from your app
and then come back.
The second is a set of
system UI visibility flags.
And the difference
with these flags
is that they're only available
in newer versions of Android,
since about Android
4.0 or later.
Additionally, these flags
are clearable by the system.
So if, for example, you
navigate away from your app
and then come back?
These flags will be cleared
and you'll have to reset them.
So the first of these
new flags is Low Profile.
And this simply dims the
status and navigation bars
when it's set.
The second is the
Fullscreen flag,
and this behaves basically
the same as the Window Manager
flag.
It simply hides the status bar.
Now, the big one here
is Hide Navigation,
which hides the navigation
bar temporarily.
For those keeping track,
the navigation bar
is the one that consists of the
Back, Home, and Recent buttons,
and it's only available
on some devices.
On some devices, the
navigation bar isn't present,
and all you would see are
soft keys like Back, Menu,
and so on.
Now, once the Hide
Navigation flag is set,
any interaction with the screen
will show the navigation bar.
And the touch events that cause
that navigation bar to show
will not be passed to your app.
This is an important
point to keep in mind when
we talk about immersive
mode in just a few seconds.
Now, one more point
before we move on.
There's a bunch of
these Layout Flags
that control how your
screens are laid out.
Setting these flags
allows your content
to appear behind
the system bars.
This is especially
important when
users can toggle the
bars in your app.
Setting these flags will keep
your content from jumping
and resizing in response to the
bar is showing or being hidden.
So let's talk about
the new stuff.
Android 4.4 introduces two new,
mutually exclusive system UI
visibility flags.
And they're immersive
and immersive sticky.
Let's look at a demo of
the immersive flag first.
So to my left, you see
the simple demo app.
Now, , when we
touch the content,
you'll see that the immersive
system UI visibility flag,
along with the Hide
Navigation, Fullscreen,
and some layout flags are set.
Once you enter immersive
mode within an app
to get back to
the system UI, you
can swipe down from
the top of the screen.
The system also automatically
presents a reminder bubble
to the user the first time
they answer immersive mode
in your app.
So here's a quick example
of that reminder bubble.
Now, an important point
here is that you're
app can now capture all the
touch events, allowing users
to, say, play an
immersive game or scroll
through content without the
distraction of system bars.
So you'll notice here
that, first, I can actually
swipe down from the top of the
screen to reveal those bars.
And then if I actually
start interacting
with the middle of
the screen, you'll
notice that the bars
actually stay hidden.
And this is the big difference
between immersive mode
and just setting the
Hide Navigation flag.
So one important point
here is that swiping
from the top of the
screen clears those flags.
So if you want to, say, hide
them again after three seconds,
you can set up a system
UI visibility listener,
which we'll talk
about in a second.
And then, three seconds
later, set the flag again
to hide them.
So let's look at some code.
First, we'll use our Windows
route view, or the Decor View,
as the anchor for
system UI visibility.
You can use any view so
long as it's visible.
Now, the next thing
you should do whenever
you use system UI
visibility flags is you
should set up a listener
to watch for changes.
Because the system can actually
clear these flags in response
to user interactions,
you want to be
kept aware of when that occurs.
Now in this case, we simply show
or hide additional UI controls
such as video playback
controls, when
the system bars are
shown or hidden.
And keeping all of
your UI controls
in sync with the system
bars is the best practice
to minimize the number of
states that your app can be in,
resulting in a more
seamless user experience.
To actually show or
hide the system bars,
you can either set or remove
the right set of flags.
To hide the system bars
and enter immersive mode,
use the Hide Navigation,
Fullscreen, and Immersive flags
in addition to the layout flags
that we talked about before.
To show the system bars,
just set the layout flags,
making sure that the
content doesn't jump.
And omit the visibility flags,
like Fullscreen and Hide
Navigation.
What that'll do is that'll
actually show the bars.
And generally,
you'll want to auto
hide the system bars after
a period of inactivity.
We won't go through
all the details here,
but basically, you
want to use a Handler
with delayed messages
for this purpose.
You can also clear messages
to make sure that any pending
hides or auto hides are
cancelled if need be.
Additionally, you
should handle the case
of Window Focus Changes.
If you gain Window
Focus, you may
want to re-hide the system bars.
If you lose Window Focus--
for example, due to dialogue
or pop up menu
coming up-- you'll
probably want to cancel
any pending auto hides.
So for example, if
you're watching a video
and you press the action
overflow, that shows up
a pop up menu, you'll
want to prevent
the case of three
seconds after you
show the action overflow, the
system bars and action bar
hide, automatically closing
the action overflow.
So this will help
you prevent that.
Lastly, you generally
want to allow users
to manually toggle the
visibility of the system bars
by touching your
content, especially
if single touches don't do
anything else in your screen.
To do this, you may think
of just using a simple click
listener.
Now the problem with this
is that click listeners
are fired even if you drag
your fingers across the content
after pressing down.
You probably don't
want to do that.
Instead, you probably want
to use a gesture detector,
like shown here, and handle
the on single tap up event.
This makes sure that if
your user's finger moves
more than just a little
bit during the touch,
it won't toggle the system bars.
Next, let's look at the
immersive sticky flag.
Now in this mode,
almost everything
is the same, except
when you swipe
from the top of the screen.
So here's that demo again,
and you see the same bubble.
Now, if you swipe from
the top of the screen,
you'll notice that a couple
of things are different.
The system bars will show up
in a semi-transparent state,
as you can see here.
And the system bars
will automatically
hide after a short delay, or
if the user interacts somewhere
with the middle of the screen.
Now, the third thing
that is different
is that the system UI
visibility change listeners
that you created before
will not be triggered.
Because this state, this
temporarily visible system
bar state, is intended
to be very transient.
And your app should basically
be completely unaware of this.
And last but not
least, the system
will not actually
clear this flag.
So when the user swipes down
from the top of the screen,
those flags will stay there.
They won't be cleared.
And this gives this
flag the sticky name.
Now, the code for immersive
sticky is really simple.
Any time the window
receives focus,
simply set the
immersive sticky flag,
along with the other
flags mentioned before.
Now you don't have to
worry about the system
clearing this flag due
to user interaction,
because again, the
flag is sticky.
OK, so let's summarize
with some use cases.
When should you use
these new flags?
So if you're building a
video player or something
else that requires
minimal user interaction,
you'll want to use something
called the lean back approach.
And this gets its name
from, you start watching,
or you turn on the
content, and you lean back.
And you don't really do
much else with the screen.
Now, the lean back
approach has been available
since Android 4.0.
It's been refined in Jelly
Bean, Android 4.1, and so on.
And it simply involves
using the full screen
and hide navigation system
UI visibility flags.
Now in this mode, in
this lean back approach,
any interaction with the
screen will automatically
show the system bars and
other playback controls
that you've defined.
if you're building
something like a book
reader or a magazine, or
something that has a little bit
more interaction, you'll
want to use the new Immersive
flag in addition to Fullscreen
and Hide Navigation.
In this case, swiping up
from the top of the screen
should reveal the system bars in
addition to your own UI chrome.
Lastly, if you're building
something truly immersive
such as a game or
a drawing app, you
may want to use the immersive
sticky flag in addition
to the Fullscreen and
Hide Navigation flags,
again, as we talked before.
In this case, swiping up
from the top of the screen
will very briefly
reveal the system bars
in a very, very transient state.
So that's immersive mode
in Android 4.4 KitKat.
Check the video
description on YouTube
for links to the sample code.
Thanks.